will the world that produced you
continue to exist and the answer is no
what is it we need to do to fix this
ladies and gentlemen it's just fight for
the right things and do it bravely
whether you're Tucker whether you're
DeSantis whether you're the parent at
the school board meeting whether you're
someone fighting covid tyranny any of
the stuff stand up and do it and you
might see a change going our Direction
This is Tucker this past weekend
and speak with total honesty Clarity and
aggression
those are the two things you need to do
now
the eating with people you agree with
and grousing is really easy that's why
those are the first things I do
when I'm mad about something I wind to
my wife about it I lecture my dogs
all of whom all four of whom agree with
me by the way
I have the most right-wing spaniels in
Maine
but
none of those things change
the outcome
you need to act you need to speak and
you need to organize and before you can
do either one of those you need to
recognize the consequences the stakes
it's not just about people doing things
you disagree with it's about
the most fundamental question of all
which is
can you have children
will they live in a world where they can
afford to get married themselves and
have children and will those children
live where you lived will they live
within driving distance of your grave
well the civilization that produced you
continue
these are I hate the word but these are
literally existential questions well the
world that produced you
continue to exist and the answer is no
with bad leadership it won't everything
is at stake and that's not a fundraising
pitch
yeah it ain't easy guys I get it it
ain't easy to say what you think and
there will be repercussions I find it
very bizarre when I'm out and about or I
do events and people say Dave you're so
brave and it's like listen I'm not going
to war right I'm not being shot at I'm
saying what I think and I guess there is
a cost and there's been a lot of upside
for it to me too but if you do not do it
what do you think is going to happen
after what do you think is going to
happen to the world that your kids are
going to live in and everything else so
we can either just as Tucker says we can
just watch TV we can just complain to
our dogs and all of those things or we
can damn well do it and it and it starts
again by telling the truth and and
Tucker talks about that often which is
why I would love uh and I absolutely
will at Tucker's welcome to come back on
the show anytime I'll text him right
after this to ask him when he'll come
back in but what I would love to know
from Tucker is what do you do about the
lies that I just laid out here it's a
little unclear to me you know look and
Tucker sometimes he does this thing
where he's sort of like commenting on
politics all the time and then and then
he pretends he has nothing to do with
politics which I think is refreshing in
a bizarre way at some level but the
question I think for someone like Tucker
is okay if you if you believe all of
these things and I believe he's being
forthright and genuine I absolutely do
like which way are you going to vote
like do you still not know I've seen
this lately with a couple pundits on the
right it's like they know what's right
but they're afraid to go against That
Base as Charlie Kirk warned me in that
video we did at the end of July you
don't want to say anything about the
bass because the bass will come after
you and Lord knows they say mean things
about me on Twitter it's true but I'm
doing all right we're gonna order lunch
today
we're gonna have lunch everything's
gonna be fine
fight for the right thing guys that's
that's the point